New York City's crisis with immigrants
illegal and otherwise has entered a new
phase
thousands are starting to move into the
city's newly opened tent complex on
Randall's Island
the shelter site which was
controversially built on top of soccer
fields for kids and now those kids have
been displaced again just like they were
during covid
now it's been expanded to House 3 000
people and the project is set to cost
New York taxpayers 20 million dollars
per month
but New York but New York's crisis is
not exclusive to the Big Apple
is now evicting 44 people from its
dormitory buildings through its college
system and that's raising concerns about
student safety but some local activists
are going after the move as Prejudiced
and wrong now some New Yorkers are
calling out the failure at our Southern
border Guardian Angels founder Curtis
Sliwa was arrested while protesting this
weekend taken away in handcuffs
[Applause]
placed under arrest on the charge of
disorderly conduct if you do not
cooperate and accompany the arresting
officer to the prisoner transport
vehicle
you maybe
so Bill what do you make of what's going
on
um where do you begin right guys uh the
Roosevelt Hotel is a mess somebody
called it a slum last week I don't think
it's too far removed from that
unfortunately I think at some point the
Roosevelt Hotel will be cleaned up I
think at some point someday Randall's
Island will be cleaned up I think
someday somehow the Border will be
concealed more than it is today
here's what disturbs me the most
fiscal year currently 2023 we're 11
months in
we have apprec we have encountered
146 people
on the terror watch list yeah that we
know of that is more than every year
combined going back to 2017. last year
it was 98 right how many was it in 2021
2023 2019 zero
2018 6 2017 too we had an entire
Congressional Commission
that was assigned the job of trying to
figure out how Saudi hijackers made
their way to San Diego California
how much time and money and National
toil did we put into that
and now you got this
you got 146 you got another month ladies
oh how's the number gonna go
what what are we thinking there was no
nation in this world that runs their
border the way we run ours well
well when you look at talking about
other nations countries like you know
the UK Australia and New Zealand who
have friendly migration policies eighty
percent of those migrants come to those
countries because of jobs here is Asylum
Seekers or Family Ties which have to
flip that script there are 1.4 million
workers on H-1B visas that are waiting
because of the backlog those are
professionals they have jobs they have
hiring managers that are waiting for
them to get back into the workplace
while we are trying to sort out what now
has costed the latest number I saw was
150.7 billion dollars a year for the
state local and federal expenses of what
migrants cause to this great nation and
here we have fires natural disasters
backlogs of people that do have
legitimate reasons and approval for
staying in this country for work yet we
cannot get you know our arms around it
so border security with a sensible and
working immigration reform is what we
need and we're not saying the quiet part
out loud Kaylee we're not saying that we
haven't just legitimized we are
complicit in sex trafficking in this
country we have ushered in law breaking
like never before it's breaking the law
to come across our border between the
checkpoints and to gain access illegally
obviously but the cartels are running
that border and they're running what
happens north of that border to young
children that we may never know the
names of but they're suffering in the
United States of America yeah Heritage
cited a statistic that as many as 60
percent of kids at the border are
trafficked so think about that I mean
these are people who are showing up and
the most heinous of conditions
vulnerable kids who are trafficked
because we have a president enabling it
um and you've got that issue and then
you've also got American children on
Randall's Island guess who's going to be
housed in that facility single adult men
at the expense of children who use that
for their soccer field that's a trend we
saw here in Manhattan where for a bit of
time it was very brief because parents
rebelled you had single adult men in
gymnasiums and the kids being displaced
yet again same thing in Brooklyn the kid
always comes less whether it's the
illegal immigrant child or the American
child in favor of in this case single
adult men well and what I would add to
that because I interviewed one of the
parents was not just that the American
kids were displaced they were right on
the same property they were right next
door to the gymnasium I mean Randall's
Island is a bit more remote but it's
thousands of people who use that Cheryl
what at what point does New York City
and other cities decide that is no
longer refusable to be a sanctuary City
at what point does New York City decide
that right to shelter does not
economically work in this country we
have watched for since covet began the
tax base of New York City flee a 12
billion dollar price tag according to
the mayor of New York City now what's
happening in Buffalo with the students
the parents stepped in and said no they
need to go again because of the sexual
assaults the MS-13 gang member over the
weekend that was caught at the border
the gunfire that was reported on over
the weekend at the border coming from
the Mexico side at border Patrol and
I'll leave it here really quick the
mental health and the lives of border
patrol agents they have done nothing but
suffer alcoholism divorce suicide it
goes on and on and at what point do we
start to care about our border agents
because at this point it doesn't seem
like the by the administration does they
are 24 7 First Responders to a national
disaster created by this President real
quick quickly what you said about
terrorism though that strikes at the
heart of every American because that's
those are the numbers that we are being
told of we don't know the demographics
of these people we don't know the crimes
they've committed they're terrorists if
you're in Isis and you're in eastern
Syria and you know the borders open what
are you going to do but of course you're
going to give a shot to put 20 guys in
the country maybe 10 of them make it and
that's 10 we don't want wow hey everyone
I'm Emily compagno catch me and my
co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights